good morning Welcome to our um
continuing uh hearings on the bill we're
going to um just break until about
probably 10:15 we're waiting on the um
ranking member and she said she'd be
about 10 minutes late so we're going to
you
okay once again we are opening our
continuing hearings on the bail uh bail
um bills that we retained and this
morning we're going to be hearing from
some more folks from the county and I
would invite them to come up to the
table if you wish to testify together
you can just pull up another chair um
all
and just please identify yourselves for
the uh
committee good morning uh Joe stanel the
superintendent at Hillsboro County
Department of
Corrections Tim conin I'm the uh booking
supervisor so if you could um whether or
not you're aware we've retained about
five or six bills that have to do with
um bail changing conditions of bail
things of that nature and what we've
been asking the counties because the
counties are the folks who end up with
these people after they've been arrested
waiting for bail or returned after bail
if you could tell us your involvement in
that system what if any kind of
pre-trial programs you have how you deal
with people that are on bail and how it
impacts you and how any changes could
impact you we'd love to hear
it well good morning again um I can talk
talk to this uh I guess I would say from
my experience obviously working in
Corrections um I've been in it for a
period of time now um every facility is
a little bit different different
counties are a little bit different um
10 jails 10 superintendents but when it
comes down to the basics of what we do
as Corrections um and and that is the
Safety and Security of of the
institution and of the community um over
the years we've seen drastic changes um
in our populations one stems from bail
reform one stem from coid um where our
populations really dropped and when I
say really dropped um uh they would they
would go from an average daily
population someplace down in Hillsboro
prior to me getting down there I do want
to say that um I was previously the
superintendent marac and up until uh
July of 22 August of 22 and then I
transitioned right over to Hillsboro so
I've been there just a little bit over a
year um their population used to sit
around I would say probably 400 500 um
daily population when I got down there
we're hovering in the mid 200s um I can
tell you today we're at 340 roughly
around
340 um the impacts of the bail um I will
say in general and and I think this is a
good platform to have this discussion is
um we are seeing individuals come in um
in the worst medical conditions that
we've ever seen them um I have ever seen
them in my experience and
Corrections um when you talk about costs
that's uh that's a sh that's that's a
large part of that now I had
uh previously we've had discussions
amongst the superintendent as you know
it's very hard to lock down what an
average daily rate is for a a individual
in custody I mean there's a formula you
can break it down with that's you take
your budget you break it down by 365 and
then and You by that you break down how
many Imes you have and you come out with
an estimated cost so let's just say if
it was
$155
right the problem with that is to give
it an actual estimated cost like that is
we could have one individual for example
that would cost us $30,000 a month in
medication costs depending on what
they're on so what I'm saying that the
the impact of and and what's been going
on um in regards to to bail and what
we're seeing and the impacts at the
level of the stakeholders in the county
jails is that um medical needs to be I
Would S medical is something that you
definitely need to be mindful of um and
then also um in regards to in regards to
the cost per day um that's the largest
driving Factor I'm gonna I'm going to
say that um my experience uh and I'm
going to ask uh Lieutenant Kon to talk a
little bit um um experience in regards
to pre-trial Services hillsbor currently
does not have a pre-trial service
program um my understanding is is that
at one point it was there was talks
about it um but at this point in time
it's it really boils down to funding too
as well um there's also a lot of other C
uh pieces that have to be put in place
with that such as who's revoking uh
their their bail status while they're
out on pre-trial
um you know do correction officers
actually have the authority to go out
and and take somebody in that's on a
pre-trial status um to my knowledge that
there uh that
isn't that there isn't any RSA or
authority that we have to do that um you
know so there's a lot of mechanisms and
Staffing that would need to be put in
place too in regards to that which all
boils down to one thing and that's
funding so is it something that um the
county would um
uh look at in the future I that is
something that I would request that we
respectfully have to have a conversation
with our commissioners and with our
funding Authority the delegation and the
executive committee
um currently right now we do have I know
there was questions about electronic
monitoring programs and so forth um
electronic monitoring for us right now
we utilize it for sentence individuals
um individuals who are on our programs
and out in the community we monitor them
in the community it costs us uh
roughly $6 and I think
37 if you just remind me for a second I
actually have the number right here
um costs us I'm
$685 per day to keep that monitor on
that individual so obviously there's a
shared cost that's associated with that
um so we obvious the the individual
that's out has to repay that cost while
they're out now there is um
that doesn't sound like a lot but when
we talk about re-entry and putting
people back into the community holding
stable
jobs um especially those who are um
experiencing substance misuse uh that
can be challenging that can be very
challenging um so I guess that's a brief
overview I mean I'd be happy to answer
any questions um I can ask Lieutenant
conine I know some of the questions were
how do we interact directly with the
bail system so those in those
individuals that are come into our
custody um you know we see we see a
various range of preventative detention
cash baales um we see a lot of PR baales
um and we're seeing a lot of repeat
individuals coming back in um and as I
said their their condition has just
worsened over time um which eventually
by the time they hit that Mark of
they're being held for a period of time
um again they're on pre- child status
but they're they've reached a mark where
they're they're definitely going to be
more costly than than they ever have
been um and that's just uh my
observations as a correction
professional and as an expert in
Corrections um it's I think that just
needs to be noted so do you have any you
to talk about how we interact with the
bill
system uh yeah so right now I know one
of the problems we're facing with the
bail system is the lack of available
bail Commissioners that are online on
any given day I know we have a handful
that we use at our facility and we are
frequently run into problems where we
have to redirect people to the courts to
have bails posted rather than being able
to call a bail commissioner down to the
jail to post it because there's just no
one available sometimes uh we have a
good relationship with the bail
Commissioners so sometimes we can get a
hold of them and have them volunteer to
come in on days they're not necessarily
working that has been a hangup with the
bail process as it stands now and I know
there's several reasons for that for the
lack of bail Commissioners I'm sure they
can speak more to that um than I could
but that is probably our biggest hang up
with people who are actually being held
in jail getting out I know we've we're
seeing more PR baales come in and go out
than I have at any other time in my
18year career seems like it's often the
same people you know once a week we see
them we say goodbye to them we see them
again the next week it's just in and out
and as he said I think that's leading
towards a lot more medical issues I
think years ago it used to be a rarity
that we'd send somebody out to the
hospital or not accept someone at intake
and now it's just we know these people
and they come back and we know as he
said the conditions are just getting
worse and worse so it's um they're
coming in they're being deflected before
they even get they have to get medically
cleared with us before they come in so
the police departments are have to take
them over and we have to try and arrange
the arrangments with the courts and get
that settled and then we go through the
whole process of getting them stabilized
and back and then it's another PR bail
and they're back out on the street and
repeating that cycle over and over again
more often um one of the things um and
I'm sure you ask some questions but
obviously with the felony felony first
roll back um that's going to bring on
some drastic changes as well we've
already began our meetings with um with
the uh public defender's office or
excuse me with the um Clerk's of Court's
office and I have a couple meetings with
my local public heads of local public
defenders office um I know the head of
the public defenders office is in the
back right there so um and just trying
to navigate that process it's going to
go essentially back to the way it used
to be um so obviously there's going to
be some changes in that status and that
will affect us as well too and
operationally so how do you see that
affecting
you uh I I I think there's going to be a
there's obviously going to be a lot more
um in and out um I think there's going
to be um individuals when you're when
you're doing the baales at the um when
they're seeing at the circuit court
level um a lot of those charges are
going to get kicked up to the felony
level um we could see our population
increase um but we could ALS it's hard
to say put my thumb on exactly what's
going to happen
but it affects us also TimeWise right
now if you look at a county like
Hillsboro I mean the other day we had
for example we had 30 roughly process 30
people in and out in one day that's
staff intensive that's I mean it it is
it's our job it's what we do um you know
video arraignments um we we have the
capability of doing video arraignments
now um you know when you talk about two
of the largest cities in in New
Hampshire Manchester and nashwa feeding
into one County Jail
all those arraignments are are going to
happen roughly probably within the same
time frame and that'll be tasking on us
not only tasking on us but'll be tasking
on the public defenders as well too so
that's how we see it impacting us so do
you have how many rooms do you have
available to conduct video arraignments
uh we have two designated rooms um that
we have to conduct actually they're
getting rebuilt right now um to be able
to conduct that but we also we utilize
tablets um we can do them right on the
housing units so um we've taken some
large steps in in that technology
advancement over the years and um gotten
creative in that way but that still
wouldn't negate the fact that obviously
those individuals are going to need to
meet with counsel prior to it so we need
to have be mindful of that and and
letting the council get in and speak
with them prior to the hearing and and
so forth so does council have the
ability to also confer with them
privately over a video if they're not
able to make it into the jail for that
currently right now um we've had cases
where we've made we've made exceptions
for that um one of the big issues that
we've seen and I know and I I will speak
from the doc's standpoint is if Council
hadn't had a chance to speak with their
client sometimes they have to ask
everybody to step out of the courtroom
and that just delays the process right
so um that's not a practice that I think
that the clerk's moving forward I think
is is really good because or or is
wanted because it's just going to
continuously have delays so we need to
be able to provide them the ability to
come in and meet with their clients I'm
sure obviously if that was the option
and that was a there was a question
about that we could work on making
exceptions to that they do have access
to call them um they have direct access
to call them there's a couple lines in
the jails where they can call in also um
they have access on their tablets where
they can where they can reach right out
to their public defender and speak to
them prior
so okay so um thank you I have just a
few questions so when you talk about
medical costs uh being the real driving
Factor what what kind of medical
conditions are we talking mostly mental
health or what's the big biggest driver
uh so the the biggest driver that we're
seeing is obviously mental health is is
um a large driver substance substance
misuse is a large driver um but what
we're seeing medical conditions
individual was coming in with um is
infections um which are requiring
significant hospital treatment because
they haven't been treated prior to
coming in um and they just let lapse um
like sepsis type sepsis is large one um
you're you're seeing um people's uh
communicable diseases um
HIV
um there's there's numerous just chronic
conditions that have never been treated
over the years or have been neglected
over the years um that just lead to
organ failure um can so many different
things just everything that you can
imagine you can imagine um we've seen it
and when we say that we then we see
something else so so um how do you
screen that obviously you can't just
look at someone and see that they are
HIV um how do you how do you get to that
process when are they screened So
currently right now um Hillsboro County
has brought in a new medical provider so
we share the same medical provider as
Rockingham Carrol County belnap County
Marat County um but even prior to that
they're screened at intake so as the PD
arrives at the facility um be prior to
admittance they're screened um if
there's a there's criteria that we look
for um say the individual is in a car
accident or so forth they're they're
unstable in their feet they have a head
injury they have open sores open wounds
um we require them to be cleared by the
hospital prior to incarceration still
they're going to come back to the to the
jail um and then there's a medical
intake that's done um within the first
uh four hours now the medical intake is
done um at the facility an initial
triage medical intake and then within 48
Hours they've had their medical intake
done how do you handle people that come
in um who have mental health issues who
have been like for example some with
schizophrenia who's off their meds how
do you how do you deal with
that it's definitely a difficult um you
know I can't commend our staff enough um
and and correction officers all over the
state um just dealing with these
individuals that are in crisis
um it's it's unfortunate um but you know
between utilization of CIT Crisis
Intervention techniques and and
um trauma informed training um our staff
have been able to deescalate those types
of situations jails aren't treat jails
aren't established to be long-term care
facilities for individuals with mental
health it's not what we do we're our
we're establish what we do is triage and
stabilize until they can require the
proper necessary care whether it be at
the New Hampshire state hospital or um
sometimes the the secure psychiatric
unit um but in the meantime obviously
we're the first stop uh unfortunately
jails in the country have become
warehouses um for those um who are in
crisis and suffering from mental health
um and the way that we process it and
the way that we deal with it is you know
we have clinicians on staff um our nurse
our medical provider um we continue
medications we get them started on
medications they meet with the provider
um they meet with our psychiatric uh
nurse practitioner um and that we do all
that via video too we can do that we
have the ability to do tele medicine too
now so um that's how we um interact with
those individuals coming in so and it
takes a lot of patience with our staff
too as well and connecting to make sure
that we're not escalating them in their
Crist in their state and also providing
them uh a safe environment as well for
our staff a safe environment so do you
have facilities to hold someone where
they can be safely held without hurting
themselves if they are in the mental
um Mental Health crisis uh without using
like padded room I mean something so we
do have we do have areas that that
provide more observation for individuals
um such as larger lexand cell doors um
we have protocols in place um for those
who are who are experiencing um
self-injurious behavior um and
requirements of what they would for
clothing food uh how they're how they're
their process processed um interacting
with staff um so we have secured cells
that that obviously we can we can
utilize yeah have you um or are you
aware of any way for you to um recoup
some of your medical expenses if the if
the if the person has for example
Medicare Medicaid to Bill to get back
for some of that so thankfully when an
individual leaves our custody right so
if they go to the hospital um
we can turn their insurance on they have
to be admitted though what we see a lot
and I will speak very candidly about
this is they get placed in an
observation period and we can't recoup
during that observation period however
if they're admitted to the hospital um
the state has worked with us and and
their Medicaid will cover their their
Hospital costs so it's only if they're
admitted though other than that when
they come in their insurance turns off
when they leave their insurance we turn
their insurance back on for them and
obviously as uh most of you are probably
familiar with this has been a Hot Topic
over the years in regards to insurance
that's it would require the federal
government to pass a law that would not
uh that would allow you to continue
billing medic even if they're Insurance
because it seems like that law was
designed to penalize people for going to
jail but if it's a mental health thing
that drove them to jail cutting off
their insurance seems counterintuitive
the cost is shifted down onto the
counties at this point do you get any
money from the state to to recoup any of
these expenses any specifically in
regards to mental health I could tell
you right now we anything yeah um we we
applied for um uh the opioid funds um
this year and we were awarded some
reimbursement um prior to this as well
too U prior to me getting there there
was a there was a sum of money that the
Hillsboro County was awarded um and we
just um we're in the final stages it's
going to GNC um I think November 3rd I
think is the next meeting so there was a
recruitment that we applied for for a
three-year period for for funds yes
would it fully reimburse you or only a
little bit or no it it would reimburse
such costs as medical assisted treatment
um cost of some of our uh staff time
there's a percentage of it um but mostly
it was surrounding around the cost for
our providers to provide the medic uh
medic medication assistant treatment in
the facility so when you mentioned a a a
person who might cost you
$30,000 um are you talking like a person
with meds like who's on HIV you has to
take a serious a lot of you can look at
a med like I we've all seen the
commercials for it you look at you look
at a med like Humera those are those are
I think I forget the I'm sorry but you
took a med like that you know on this on
the street it's and when I say on the
street I mean outside of the jail if you
don't have insurance on it it's about
$30,000 a month so um we could go to the
provider you know we all have insurance
and and we go to the provider we pay
like $40 but those individuals that it's
a it's a very expensive cost so so you
pay full price if we we would yeah yeah
um do you have you tried reaching out to
any of the pharmaceutical companies and
had any success with
them so we utilize um uh like currently
right now um our medical provider um has
a pharmacy that they utilize Westwood um
Pharmacy is is what they do um there's
other jails there's other other jails
use different pharmacies um it all
depends you know on what the cost is you
go out to RF we utilize the RFP process
for that as well yeah to get the best
price um on those medications a lot of
the a lot of the companies have um are
able to restock um unused medications um
which provides us a kickback obviously
and and uh reimbursement so okay um my
next question was
regarding tracking of of do you have any
ability to track if someone is let go on
PR and they come back 3 or 4 days later
are you able to track those numbers of
people who who reoffend and come back in
while they're on an original
bail uh we can sorry we can certainly
track an individual who's releasing when
they come back in you know based on that
um just their inmate number we can see
how many times they've been back and how
recently as far as just a general
tracking of whether or not there unless
we're specifically looking for it um it
wouldn't be wouldn't necessarily come up
once are on PR bail they're out of our
system we're not tracking them at that
point so there's it's not a like I
couldn't pull you a number right now and
see how many inmates we've released on
PR bail that are still out on PR bail
and or how many times they've come back
well out on bail so would your system be
able to do that if that were something
that were
required it could it could assist with
that um just so that we would be able to
get a number in the future like over a
year how many people are let out and
then come back within while they're
still on the original bail yeah we could
use the system as well as some other
resources that we wouldn't have to use
to to track that information but that
that could be done over um if it was
done intentionally over a period of time
okay yeah I asked because I don't want
to mandate something that can't be done
without funds so um go ahead you wanted
to say something yeah um one of the
things I would note with that is that um
those arrested in other counties so we
won't know necessarily that somebody was
arrested in Rockingham County yeah um
and and we see that when we do our
recidivism numbers for like our
programming and so forth um because the
national average I believe is around 60%
and then um you know for a place like
Hillsboro County when I we did a
recidivism study this past year um in
our program uh we're sitting about
anywhere from in three-year period 27 to
30% re civism those are sentenced
individuals that re offended within one
year coming back to the facility and
Lieutenant conine is our data individual
so he's the best person for us to be
asking this question of right now so I
want to keep in touch with you yeah um
he but to track that within our County I
mean it would take some leg work on on
our end but um he'd be happy to take a
look I'm sure in the if you could if
it's possible I don't want to ask you to
move their world but if it's if some
retooling of the of the system is
possible so that you could track
individuals who came back while they
were out on bail so we would have harder
numbers on that
um let me see
um with regard to you said that you have
some difficulty getting bail
Commissioners um is that something new
that's getting worse or is it something
that's kind of been steady in the county
uh it started we used to have I going to
say a couple years ago we used to have a
bail commissioner on 247 that we can get
a hold of we share of bail commission
with Manchester PD so they would swing
back and forth between each of those and
probably starting within the last Sor
just time blurs together so sometime in
the last couple years it's it went from
us occasionally having a day where we
had no bail commissioner on to it's ebed
and Float a little bit to we oftentimes
have multiple days a week where we have
no bail commissioner available would
that be over a weekend that you're
talking about mostly very candidly at
like to say this one of my one of the
things I noticed one day um like over
Memorial Day weekend I believe it was um
I think I want to say it was memor the
weekend there wasn't a bail commissioner
on from Thursday till I think Tuesday of
the following week so we didn't have
anybody that we could call and that's
not only frustrating for for us it's
frustrating for the the I would assume
and I want to speak for them the public
defender office um as well too um and
and also the PDS um because people are
on vacation and that's what people do
people take vacations and um when
there's only a limited amount of bail
Commissioners that's that so that whole
weekend people that would normally be
entitled to bail had to sit in jail the
entire weekend we were I think we were
able to get a hold of a bail
commissioner um in a couple couple
accounts but again they would either sit
with us or they'd sit with the PD yeah
so if they have a holding facility
um I'm going to ask that everybody in a
second
um with regard to electronic monitoring
do you see any bail Commissioners ever
Avail themselves of that as a condition
of
bail and if so who would uh who would
monitor so we've seen it utilized the
company I off the top what's
theany Paris Bail Bonds out of
Connecticut have done that has has done
that in Hillsboro County um and they
would up put a bracelet on um or they'
have somebody in the area put a bracelet
on them and monitor as a condition
usually the condition comes down from
the courts though okay that would be in
a cash bail situation probably when they
use the bail bonds out of conect yes
okay if if it were utilized by bail
Commissioners um as part of a PR
bail um would would it still be the same
687 a
day that that cost cost varies um in my
experience as throughout my career um
again you go through it would all it
would all depend on what that company
chooses to charge them um and also
whoever they're utilizing from like what
monitoring system there's multiple ones
there's Sentinel there's track group uh
Omni link there's so many different um
groups out there that do it um so it
really would require who's given
whatever price they're getting versus
and versus how much they're charging so
well the committee I mean candidly we're
here because the public is is is
expressed a certain level of
uncomfortableness with the number of
people that are being bailed released
bailed released and committing crimes
while on bail and at the same time we're
looking at how we can not say okay
you're all going to be held at the
expense of the county and also to
disrupt people's lives
unnecessarily I feel like um electronic
monitoring implementation would be much
cheaper to the county than having them
stayed in there with all their medical
expenses and everything else so we're
trying to look at that as a possibility
to versus just being held on certain
crimes it definitely would be a cost
shift on to the county um obviously with
that because we require Staffing as well
too yeah um and you know one of the
things that there's obviously would need
to be conditions that would be met to
put somebody out um in the community
because you would still see the same
thing of them coming back and continuing
to come back I it would need to be
monitored while they're out there we
have utilized it in instances very
specific instances where um somebody's
medical situation is so drastic that it
would require hospitalization for an
extended period of time we have um and
the public defender office prosecution
have have worked with us in order to um
allow us to to put a bracelet on them
and and keep them there which has shown
a large um savings to the county so it
does that's what I'm asking would it be
would it be more cost effective for the
county to hold somebody um hold them
actually or to continue to let them on
PR but with a
monitor and it seems to me the monitor
would be much more cost effective than
again I think it would be I mean either
one is going to cost you money either
one's going to cost um it would defin
definitely vary on the person on the
individual too that's the hardest part
to say will they obey other conditions
regard yeah okay um questions from the
committee representative
roads thank you Mr chairman you had
mentioned about the the lack of bell
Commissioners it's not the first time
we've heard that I'm sure you that you
understand that H how many times or I
guess how many attempts will you make to
call a bill commissioner before you
just you know like Hillsboro wow like
you know how you know like are you doing
this you know are you calling every hour
are you just calling two or three like
do you call two or three times and then
that's it they what what would be your
your Norm or your standard if we have a
bail commissioner scheduled we'll call
them repeatedly if we have no bail
commissioner scheduled our first call is
usually the Manchester Police Department
to kind of see hey you got to see if
they're using anyone if they've already
talked to somebody who can come in um
and after that if they say no we haven't
used anyone then uh we'll kind of hold
call some of the bail Commissioners that
we know on their days off that aren't
scheduled to see if they're available to
come in and if they answer and agree to
come in then that works out for us if we
call around and we can't get through to
anybody then there's nothing else we can
really do at that point yeah we I found
in my in my career too um you know
there's certain there's certain bail
Commissioners that you know that will go
above and beyond and come in and you
know as as you work in these agencies
you develop that relationship with them
and because our goal isn't to hold
anybody um that that for bail that has
the ability to get out on bail because
again that becomes a cost for us it's
there's potential liability associated
with every individual that we house in
custody too so if we can get them out we
want to get them out
so yeah just a follow up on her question
do you have like a um in do do the bail
Commissioners in your county do do they
have like um like who's going to be
covering this weekend or any type of
that thing or is it just you just start
calling on a list we they they send us a
schedule uh monthly and then up you know
to thank you how often are you seeing uh
individuals with their bill being
violated that are detained until they
levels they come in on VI on violations
of bail yeah they come in violation of
bail they're bail has been violated they
come back with either a cash bail from
the court or they end up staying with
you until they have trial is that
something you're seeing a lot of
recently or no uh we do
have a good fair amount of individuals
coming in with the breach of bail
charges unfortunately I wouldn't feel
comfortable giving you a number as far
as how many of what what's that turns
into after there rign i' have to it's
not something I've necessarily looked at
at this point
so just like to follow up on that um I
will give you a number um I think it was
at my last board meeting it was roughly
I think 28 people that we had in custody
that were in custody for over 365 days
as
pre-trial that's a lot of individuals
and obviously there is a whole the whole
court process with you know all the
court proceedings going on but that was
that's a lot of individuals to be
housing um jails aren't designed to
House people longer than a year that's
just not what we are so follow follow up
I would assume those cases are probably
felony level cases that are more serious
in nature than Mr demeanors most of them
yes right thank
you any other questions from the
committee representative wheeler I just
missed the number when you had said it
um what is the recidivism right for
Hillsboro County again so if you look at
the the national level I would say the
national level roughly is around 60%
65% um when you look at our program and
I was talking specifically previously
what was known as sacko um there were
three-year recidivism studies so those
individuals that were sentenced to our
sacko program um and our our numbers are
right on the website too so if you want
to take a look at this all the data is
right on there um and it's very
interesting because it'll it breaks down
um what they've been brought back in on
probation hold uh new charges and so
forth um hovered between 27 to 30%
recidivism for those that were sentenced
in our program so obvious the program is
working and we've revamped it and um
made it a little bit more robust now and
it's we call it the ACT program
so uh it's available to those
individuals that are sentenced
um oh right on the County website if you
go on to um Hillsboro County um if you
go under the Department of Correction s
and it should be under the ACT program
there's a slideshow talks about um uh um
treatment programs inside the facility
and you can see the data right on there
and that was Lieutenant conin I who did
that so um thank
you several other counties we talked to
seem to have some pretty successful
pre-trial programs have you been in
touch with them are you aware of what
they're doing some of them seem to be
actually realizing significant cost
savings by utilizing that uh as as I
stated earlier I came from a county that
was that was utilizing a pre-trial
service program um it it definitely has
come it's definitely continued to to
evolve um and I I mean I have seen I
have seen it I will say that I have seen
it um again I would just it would be the
the will of the commissioner and their
funding Authority about the because it
will cost us um some more money
obviously there's cost associated with
operating full-time pre-trial
programs having probably the most um
turnover in the in the state as far as
people comeing in and out we have the
largest facility um we probably process
the most people in and out um in that
facility uh on a daily basis than any
other facility in the state so we do if
the um if the state made a a fund
available that had certain requirements
that a county would have to meet to
apply to that fund f with regard to a
pre-art program do you think that would
something that would be interesting to
to Hillsboro County I I would be I would
urge us to to approach the the Board of
Commissioners and the delegation um
about that obviously because it's a it's
a cost associated with it so I mean from
okay pretend they all said yeah which is
something that that the uh the doc would
find um I think I think you find um it's
it would it would fall back on how how
the program is going to operate I think
there's a lot of there would be a lot of
um research that would need to be done
into it um because most programs operate
differently I know maramax operates
underneath um the human services
department straford operates out of the
jail Rockingham operates out of the jail
I know marac used to operate out of the
county attorney's office so um I think
it would just be a collective approach
within the county that
that multiple agencies would have to and
stakeholders would have to buy into and
and figure out what process works the
best for Hillsboro so uh yeah I was
thinking more of of the state looking at
doing that leg work and finding the best
practices and saying okay look we've got
X number of dollars if you implement a
program that has these things you can be
eligible to apply to that program for
money to reimburse you for running it
that would that be something I think
we're I think everybody wants to save
some money so and get some money from
somewhere so yeah um I I think that
again I just think it would be a a
conversation that we need to occur with
the funding Authority and the for
Commissioners represent Stone thank you
you happen to spark my interest on
something given the circumstances where
each County operates independently and
sets their own programs and parameters
and we've heard testimony last week
where uh you think it was uh it was
marac and straford
and when it came to violating the
pre-trial one would be a letter sent to
the court and another one would be sent
to the county attorney would be better
served in your experience that maybe the
probation parole department for the
state would be expanded on to include
making it a bigger umbrella to include
pre-trial confinement monitoring whether
than putting in people in
jail I would my experience and I know
this was a question that we had asked
about probation and parole um I know
from my experience working with prob in
parole um and speaking with them
obviously it falls under the state um
that they are stretched really thin
right now um I
I I don't know if they would have the
resources to do that um if they were to
expand their resources then I would say
that would probably be a Comm a
conversation with commissioner Hanks and
and um uh Field Services uh um
agency so I mean it could go two ways I
guess I would say it it would it's
there's going to be a cost either the
county or or the state at that point and
they doing the same job function it's
would be the same whether and you know
New Hampshire doesn't have County
Probation um if New Hampshire was to go
down that road of County Probation
obviously there would be funding
associated with that as well too so and
that would shift the cost from the state
down onto the county and obviously there
would need to be some cost shiftings and
saving and to the county if that if they
were to take that over so thank you it
it just the observation that I I mean
I'm not going to speak for the committee
but I have seen during the hundreds of
hours of hearings we've had
um first of all I'm a state
representative but I'm also a citizen of
a county and it seems to me that the
states is is creating laws that make
crimes sentencing people for breaking
those laws and telling the county to pay
for it is that pretty much accurate I
mean very Loosely speaking
there is there is some cost shifting yes
and the cost shift comes onto the county
and it could be a citizen from another
County who lives his whole life in the
other County commits a crime in your
county and now he's a citizen of yourk
County until he's released I give you a
very clear example parole violations
individuals with parole violations that
pick up new charges they are
responsibility of the county but yet
they are on parole violations they are
not they are not picked up until those
County charges have been resolved
so that individual who is under parole
supervision just and they I understand
they picked up new charges but they're
still under a house of cor I mean a
state prison sentence and supervision
and they and that gets transferred down
to the county and we sit on them until
all those charges are resolved so if
they were not on parole they would have
been eligible for just bail and it would
have been routine proc they'd still be
eligible for bail they're still eligible
for bail on their new charges if they
get bailed on their new charges they we
were transfer for them to the state
prison if they're not bailed on their
new charges then they sit with us even
though they were a
parole representative
Stone I can't imagine a lot of people
prison have you had people decline to to
take
bail I'm uh I've seen people decline
bail over my years yes thank you any
further questions from the committee
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony today thank you very much for
your
time and um at this time we have
somebody from the public defender office
us and I know you have an incredibly
busy schedule and I really thank you for
come thank you good morning everybody
thank you for um taking my testimony
this morning my name is Sarah Rothman I
am the executive director of the New
Hampshire public defender um I've been
with the public defender for 16 years um
and I've been in my role um for about a
year a little bit over a year um I think
I had the opportunity to speak with you
some months ago um at the beginning of
the session um just to kind of give you
an overview of what the public defender
does but just very briefly I can tell
you um you know we are sort of the One
Stop Shop for um you know Public Defense
or for um criminal defense in New
Hampshire uh we represent roughly about
85% of all criminal defendants in the
state of New Hampshire um there is We
Exist by Statute um there's a statute in
New Hampshire that says that um the
state shall contract with a law firm um
to provide uh defense to Indigent um
defendants um and we are uh we we bid
for a contract every two years we are a
private nonprofit Law Firm um we bid for
a contract every two years with the
judicial
Council um and then obviously we're also
you know aside from statutorily required
also constitutionally under the federal
and the state constitution um required U
for anybody facing potential jail time
to be afforded uh an attorney if they
can't afford one and if they qualify
after applying with the court um so I
again thank you for the opportunity to
allow me to address um from from my
perspective from the public defender
perspective um you know some of the
issues with the the current legislation
that's pending with regarding uh with
regards to bail um I do want to say uh
you know at the outset I I kind of want
to Echo um a lot of what
um the previous testimony um which is
that the the changes the proposed those
changes um to the bail statute um simply
cannot be sustained um financially or
logistically um by the public defender
by the prosecutor's offices across the
state and by the courts um I I I hope
that I can impress uh upon everybody
that the significant change that this
will represent the significant volume
increase that this will represent um and
I also want to try and impress that it
would be a change without um without
need um because of several factors that
I'd like to get into this morning um so
I I think it will cause you know a an
explosion of the number of bail hearings
cover sure so the list of you know there
different bills have different lists but
adding 12 to 13 offenses um that you are
just prohibited from seeing a bail
commissioner for um and must be held um
until you can go in front of of a judge
um so those are people who right now and
I understand that there are you heard
and you've heard over the weeks um
testimony about the lack of bail
Commissioners um and um certainly I
think that there's a lot of solutions we
could bring to that particular problem
um that do not involve um just cutting
out Bail Commissioners um bail
Commissioners even though um it's a
resource that is limited um provides a
really important function in the system
um which is to evaluate whether people
actually need to be held um to see a
judge and if we create you know 12 or 13
statute statutes that they are just not
allowed to see a bail commissioner um we
are going to see a huge explosion in the
number um of incarcerated bail hearings
that my office will then have to cover
on a daily basis that prosecutors and
judges and Court staff um will have to
cope with um you know and the reason
that these people when they see a bail
commissioner are currently released um
is because um you know they are a good
candidate for bail um so these are
people this volume of people that we're
currently not seeing we're not seeing
them because we don't need to see them
um and I want to get into that a little
bit further um but just to kind of start
at the outset to talk about the impact
that this would have um you know
financially and I guess I can't speak in
too concrete of terms financially except
to say that um this will require us to
have more staff and require um a lot
more attorney time from us um you know
right now whether I'm prepared to kind
of quantify that in a dollar amount not
necessarily but I can say more um is is
a good way to say that um I I guess I
would also encourage um Everybody if you
haven't already to look at the fiscal
note um that's there for Senate Bill 252
that's also pending um that one that
bill has a fiscal note um from the
judicial branch about the impact of
adding all of these statutes to a list
um of folks who will not be able to see
a bail
commissioner um so you know if they're
not able to see a bail commissioner uh
that means that they need to have um a
lawyer appointed to them um obviously
these folks would have a lawyer
appointed to them at some point anyway
um but these are you know what we often
refer to as same day or next day
hearings um so these are our our
defendants that we find out about at in
the best case scenario late afternoon
the day before but in almost all
instances the day of the hearing so um
you know sometime in the morning we get
a list and then slowly paperwork starts
to trickle in um you know the the
charges against the person and an arrest
warrant affidavit um and then there's a
whole process that we have to go through
on our end to conflict check and to get
a lawyer present um to represent that
person and then as you've heard uh
briefly earlier this morning there's
logistical issues and being able to talk
to that person um prior to their hearing
um and
you know sometimes you know we work
County by count to create systems to try
and be able to do that um but um you
know those systems are not perfect um
and it can be very difficult to access
our clients before these hearings um and
particularly you know there there's in
in an ideal world there's back and forth
right you talk with your client you find
out some information and then you talk
with the prosecutor um because it is
possible to negotiate bail or to
negotiate conditions of bail um so then
you talk with the prosecutor and then
you know you want to talk to your client
again and you're lucky enough a lot of
times to have one conversation with your
client before this hearing and let alone
another one um so there's this whole
process that has to take place that we
already do um but now we are talking
about expanding that um to a whole
population of people who otherwise um
could have had access to a bail
commissioner and potentially not be held
and not need that same day hearing um
which will take um time and resources
from the public defender from
prosecutors um and from Court staff um
we are and I you know I don't want to
Sidetrack us too much on this but the
public defender um continues to struggle
with our staffing levels um we continue
to face very very steep attrition um we
um have
lost since July 1 um as of tomorrow will
we we will be down nine attorneys um
since July 1 um as of November 1st we we
will be down 10 attorneys and as of
January we will be down 12 attorneys um
and so um people uh and at fiscal year
the last fiscal year 23 we lost 22
attorneys um so by January we will
already be at 12 um and Counting so um
it is already um you know difficult for
us to staff the workload that we
currently have um you know I think that
um some committee members might be aware
that um during the pandemic we had to
put certain categories of cases on hold
to wait assignment of council we have
largely cleared that list um and are now
back to assigning cases upon receipt
from the court um but case Lo case loads
among our staff are are consistently
high again um and it's then it feeds
this cycle of attrition you know the the
workload is too much and too stressful
um and the pay is not enough and so
people leave um and it might seem kind
of abstract to tie change to the bail
law to increase attrition at the at the
public defender but it's not abstract um
you know if we add in additional you
know bail hearings on a daily basis um
you know we're already going to be doing
bail hearings um but you know a even to
get sometimes a bail agre an agreement
on bail um for one client can take two
to three hours and so now if you're
trying to do that on behalf of four and
five clients because there's people who
did not have access or not allowed to
see a bail commissioner um you know then
we're talking about half of or more than
half of your day um working on just bail
hearings um when you have a lot of other
kinds of hearings you have to go to the
jail to meet with other clients you have
motions you need to write you know all
of the other things that we need to do
during our day um and so I just I I want
to emphasize that you know the system is
is has had you know reached a Breaking
Point a couple of years ago um and kind
of buckled and we've kind of tried to
claw our way back um but as um you know
you heard in the previous testimony as
of January 1 there's already going to be
significant change to the system um that
I think will cause uh arraignments and
bail hearings to to be more time
consuming as it is um for our office uh
and with these changes um if these
proposed changes with creating a you
know a list of 12 or 13 offenses um that
are automatic holds um people are not
entitled uh to bail until seeing a judge
um you know I it going to be difficult
to impossible to staff and sustain that
work
um felony's first change Y how is that
going to impact your office um if you
could it's my understanding that in the
first instance felonies were being heard
in Superior Court now they're all
shifting back to the Circuit Court would
you not have to appear at either one of
those or what's the difference that
right yeah that's a great question so
you know right now we staff um the
felony arraignments in 10 Superior
Courts in the state um and so now we are
going from Staffing 10 courts to
Staffing 31 circuit courts um and we um
most of the counties now will transport
defendants to the courthouse um and so
we don't have to do this giant struggle
of trying to get in touch with our
clients at the jail either by you know
by phone um you know going to the jail
is sometimes an option but often not an
option because if you're at the jail you
don't have access to talk to anybody
else um so you can't talk to the
prosecutor you can't um or it could be
very difficult in a lot of cases it's
impossible um there might be one or two
houses of Corrections that allow you to
you know write emails or something from
the jail but um so anyway being at the
jail is is usually not much of an option
and so currently we're able to send
attorneys to the courthouse um to staff
those arraignments um come January 1
again it's going to be spread out over
31 courts um they defendants are by and
large we've been told not going to be
transported um they're going to appear
by video um and so we're going to have
to do this um this struggle every
morning to try to talk to these clients
you know we have to wait to get
paperwork to to have something to talk
to them about um and so then a lot of
times the window between when we have
their charges and when the heing is
supposed to start is very small um and
you might have telephone access but
there might be one phone line and you're
you know you're fighting against
everybody else who wants to use that
phone line um so um it's a huge
logistical issue for us um the shift
back um to Circuit Court I mean in other
ways that are not really relevant here
today we're excited that you know these
are shifting back to Circuit Court we
hope that that will lead to you know
quicker resolution of cases and I think
that was a big point of of bringing them
back to the Circuit Court um to try to
shorten the timeline life of these cases
to try and resolve them um a lot of
felonies get
resolved excuse me as misdemeanors in
Superior Court anyway so why don't we do
that sooner in the process um so there's
a lot of advantages of it I don't want
to make it sound like I'm I'm against
you know the return to Circuit Court but
it does present a lot of logistical
challenges for us that it's just going
to take time it's going to take attorney
time it's going to take support staff
time um so um you know that's a big
change that we are preparing for come
January 1 anyway um um and um you know
we are hoping um right now the public
defender uh unfortunately Statewide is
not staff incarcerated misdemeanor
arraignments Statewide we do it in some
parts of the state where we can um but
in other parts of the state you know one
office covers six different circuit
courts and they can't they simply just
cannot send attorneys um to six
different circuit courts to cover these
misdemeanor incarcerated arraignments um
now we are hoping um that there all
arraignments incarcerated arraignments
are going to be out of the Circuit Court
they're all going to be by video um we
are hoping to be able to staff
incarcerated misun arraignments more
than we currently are um and so that
will be an increase in our in our
workload and then if we add again this
list of offenses um then that's another
increase as well um so um you know I I
think that well you could say well you
know not that you are offering this but
you know once it we'll give you more
money um okay you know that sure um but
doesn't make staff appear um you know
certainly I I I think that um you know
we've done some adjustments to our pay
if we could do more you know that could
potentially help with retention um but
at the end of the day um it just it we
need bodies we need the people um and so
it's not necessarily just about money um
so I guess kind of Shifting to because I
I understand one of the reactions to
this might be to say I hear what you're
saying you know we get it this is going
to be you know but this is what we have
to do for Public Safety this list of 12
to 13 offenses these offenses are so
serious um that sometimes you just have
to make the law and then make it work um
and so I definitely want to speak to
that point because I I don't believe
that to be true um you know the the list
of offenses certainly I am not trying to
um you know minimize um the seriousness
of those offenses number one if they are
proven to be true right um and one thing
to keep in mind is that when we're
talking about bail all of these people
are Presumed Innocent um and um and so
that's you know that that's a very big
factor but even even um kind
of the even kind of a not assuming that
these folks are guilty but assuming that
you know that these are serious
potentially a serious offenses um some
of these folks you know might need to be
held um and and don't get me wrong you
know this list of offenses people do get
held for these offenses under current
statutory scheme um so that's you know
that's one of the points that I want to
make I know you've heard that um you
know it it sounds like maybe you're
hearing a little bit that the bail
commissioner system is broken I mean the
bail commissioner system is not perfect
but it offers um a lot of benefit in
that it's a you know an a relatively
quick um way to assess somebody for
whether they are appropriate for release
um and you know so it's not as if seeing
a bail commissioner means that you're
never going to get held for those
offenses is this list of offenses this
list of 12 to 13 people get held for
these offenses all the time and then it
goes for a judge and they do have a bail
hearing um but the the fact that there
are people who are charged with these
more serious offenses with aggravated
fonia sexual assault with you know
possession of child pornography um you
know with second deegree assault um
domestic violence um the fact that those
people see a bail commissioner and are
still released um tells you uh that
those are not people who need to be held
um and um this list of offenses and I'll
talk kind of separately about people who
violate bail and I can address that but
in terms of just looking at their
charges and saying look you you don't
deserve to see a bail commissioner you
need to see a judge you need to be held
um you know I think that it's it's easy
um to sort of rely on anecdotes in that
regard um but you know to say that oh
this this particular offense you know
here's this one thing I read about in
the newspaper um that person I can't
believe that they were released on bail
um and I think some of that comes back
to more of the people who are accused of
violating their bail but in terms of um
you know these lists of offenses uh you
know number one um you know I there is
in the the the fiscal note to Senate
Bill 252 gets gets into this in
particular um there are misdemeanor
charges that are on this list um and so
the idea that you would not be able to
see a bail commissioner and that you
were going to be held U per se just
um on misdemeanor charges um is um you
know it we would be incarcerating people
who would otherwise never be
incarcerated um and um some of you might
have you know seen research about you
know even two nights in jail and the you
know terrible impact that that can have
on your life you know the way it can
just make your life unravel um in terms
of losing housing losing Insurance
losing jobs losing child custody um and
then also the trauma ass associated with
spending any time in jail um but um you
know beyond that the the fiscal note for
Senate Bill 252 talks about the
incredible volume of bail hearings that
that will result in and I can say
unequivocally if um you know domestic
violence under RSA 631 Tob is just per
se you don't get to see a bail
commissioner that will result in just an
astronomical number uh of bail hearings
that the system is just not at all
prepared to absorb
um I'm talking about the misdemeanor
level in particular um and then also I I
want to kind of talk to I know I I again
don't want to to be seen as kind of
minimizing oh it's just misdemeanor
domestic violence any domestic violence
if it's true you know needs to be
addressed um but um these charges
misdemeanor domestic violence is any
unprivileged physical contact um and um
you know not to to fight anecdotes with
anecdotes but but I can tell you my
first bench trial when I was a b brand
new lawyer was on a misdemeanor uh
simple assault domestic violence charge
and my client was charged with a shower
poof you know the the fluffy little poof
um he threw it at his he was charged
with throwing it at his partner um and
that was a misdemeanor domestic violence
charge um and that's not just an
anecdote I mean that is it is literally
if I walk I brush past your shoulder as
I walk through a doorway um you know
there's just any you know unprivileged
contact and that's what we're talking
about I'm sorry know knowing yes it
can't be act it has to be knowing yeah
not necessarily intentional but knowing
um so you know and then also when we
look at like misdemeanor stalking under
633 3A um you know I think that stalking
of often conjures up an image of
somebody you know hiding out outside in
your bushes behind you know at your in
front of your house um you know sitting
in your car in their car you know
waiting for you um you know stop
stalking is essentially um you know if
you violate a no contact order um and so
almost the vast majority of these are um
you know text messages and phone calls
and a very good percentage of those are
actually contact that is initiated by
the alleged victim that the defendant is
responding to um which again you know
this defendant has either a bail order
or a protective order you know something
that says that they're not supposed to
do that so um I'm not saying that these
charges um come out of nowhere but when
we think about are they a danger to the
community for sending a text message you
correct it's actually right so it
depends on how the police department or
the prosecutor's office charges it um
but a lot of times um the stocking is
used um for that purpose that's
correct um and then you know to move on
to um you know even second degree
assault um under
6312 um you know those those offenses
can similarly be you know minor
relatively minor in in nature um you
know contact that does not result in any
kind of injury um um and uh you know I
think that often in the domestic
violence contact UM those are
allegations of choking
um you know often there is really no
evidence to support that um and we often
in contested bail hearings um you know
when contested bail hearings you know
because of lack of evidence but also um
because it it sounds when you hear the
word choking it it can sound more
serious than really when you hear a
little bit more about the facts of the
case or and in combination of hearing
more about you know the fact that a
defendant you know has a place to live
that is nowhere you know has nothing to
do with the alleg victim you know has a
job um you know has other factors that
make them a good candidate for bail um
these are again people that the bail
Commissioners are seeing and are are
deciding um that they can be released um
that they don't need to be held um and
then even again the the more serious uh
offenses that are listed here aggravated
fonia sexual assault uh and fonia sexual
assault um and you know possession um of
child abuse sexual images or computer
pornography um you know those charges um
often those those those clients those
defendants are are getting bail um and
you that might be surprising to folks
how could you be charged with rape or
possession of child pornography and get
bail um you know again I think I would
come back to number one you know that
the presumption of innocence um but you
know a lot more than that it is very
common for charges in those in those
scenarios particularly uh afsa and FSA
um to be to be old um you know the
allegations are from several years prior
um they are not recent allegations in a
lot of instances um for various reasons
um and um so often um you know the the
defendant has no contact anymore with um
you know with the alleged victim or or
their family um and then again these are
often people who have other factors that
make them good candidates for because
we're not punishing them at this phase
for committing this offense we're
deciding are they you know a safe um
person to release into the community uh
and these people charged with these
offenses very often have no criminal
record um and have stability have
housing have jobs um and so and then
also have the ability to add a number of
bail conditions um that that assure you
know for instance no contact but also
can assure um that they not use
electronic devices um you know as
particularly in child pornography cases
um and things like that so there are
bail conditions that can be set for
these folks and um you know I think in
my 16 years of experience people charged
with those higher level
offenses F afsa FSA you know the child
porn charges um are actually not prone
to violating their bail or even their
conditions of bail um you know these are
not the folks that we are seeing you
know you hear about this kind of
revolving door and those are folks who
are struggling with substance use
disorder and with homelessness um and
that you know who are charged with
possession or thefts or things of that
nature that are related to their
substance use disorder um these are
people um who again have a lot more
stability and are good candidates for
bail and who follow their bail
conditions when you tell them not to
have contact um you know they they abide
by that and they largely um you know
remain out on bail um because the
alternative is is what you just heard
about pre you know that previously is
that there's people um sitting in jail
for more than a year pre-trial um who
otherwise you know potentially with some
of the options that you you seem that
you are exploring here in this committee
like electronic monitoring and pre-trial
Services um would would have been um an
excellent candidate for those kinds of
programs um you know I I don't work in
corrections but you ask the question you
know is that a cost savings you know
those types of programs um you know I I
believe that they are um and a cost
savings also you know to the public
defender program as well um and that
kind of leads into you know the next
category which is you know people who
violate their bail and how do we address
um the idea that you know there's people
who kind of come back again and again um
you know number one I I don't um I
haven't seen a lot of data that that
really actual hard empirical data that
demonstrates that this is somehow um
that there's been a spike in this
happening um you know that there's some
sort of um you know epidemic of of bail
violations that are going around um you
know we do have um we have very real
substance use disorder problems in this
state um we have um you know act a big
Mental Health crisis we don't y I ask
you a question about the data yes um
do you have a source of data that we're
not available because we can't it
doesn't seem to be a place you can get
data that's kind of what I was saying I
was saying I I haven't seen data that
actually says it doesn't exist so we
have to rely on what we hear from from
the law enforcement from the bail
Commissioners from the jails I mean I I
I hate to rely on anecdotes but that's
all we have because we we don't have a
way to pull thata based on the the the
fractured court system we have it so if
you have a a good source of data we
would love to hear it but so sure so I
mean I my system doesn't also doesn't
provide for tracking like somebody was
out on bail um and returns you know to
jail um I don't from my system I don't
have um the ability to track that um and
so I certainly appreciate your point
then you know what else can we do I
guess I can share my perspective then
you know doing this work for 16 years um
you know certainly the opioid um you
know pandemic that we suffered or we're
still suffering in this state has
increased you know people who are who
are sick um and who are struggling um
but um and I I don't from my point of
view I have not seen some sort of
explosion it it's been pretty persistent
I mean there there is a population of
people who struggle with homelessness um
in particular I think because right now
we're talking about you know violating
bail um by almost always committing a
new drug offense um or you know maybe
you missed court because you're homeless
and then when they you get arrested on
that warrant you have drugs in your
possession a small amount of drugs in
your possession um and so I want to
emphasize though that the current bail
scheme already has solutions to those
issues um you know there are ways to to
revoke bail if it's serious enough um
there are ways um to factor in failures
to appear when deciding on bail um and
uh you know there are ways certainly if
you get arrested for a new offense and a
bail commissioner sees that you're
already out on bail um he might not he
or she might not release you and might
have you wait to see a judge to decide
if if you should get out um so there's
already these mechanisms that exist um
to to deal with people who are accused
of violating the conditions of their
bail um and by and large the people who
are accused of that are not violent
people who are out committing new
violent offenses um these are people who
are just still struggling with their
mental mental health and with their
substance use disorder issues and with
their homelessness um and so the
solution for that um is not to hold them
in jail and I don't just say that from
my public defender heart right um I say
that um in that it it doesn't it doesn't
work it just doesn't solve anything um
and so given that that these potential
changes to the bail statute would cost I
I think would result in costs um to the
public defender to Prosecutor's offices
to the courts um and it sounds like you
already doing this but I would encourage
you if we're going to incur costs it
should be um to spread pre-trial service
programs um you know I'm familiar
somewhat with the programs here in marac
County the program in stford County um
they are excellent models um and I think
that you know much like now drug court
is statutory and Statewide um you know I
think that pre-trial Services should be
statutory and Statewide um I think that
you know diversion programs um so those
are programs where um you um it's
essentially if you complete a pre-trial
Services type program or a divers or
this this type of program supervision
pre-trial with with conditions with
treatment with a treatment plan for you
if you complete that you can avoid um
you know you can avoid conviction um and
I I think that those are the areas that
that we need to focus on and those are
areas that are much easier for my office
to staff right we can we can deal with
um you know even if the client has
regular planned um scheduled court dates
to comply with their pre-trial
supervision program which largely they
don't um usually once somebody's put on
pre-trial Services you know we the
public defender the lawyer obviously
that's our client and we keep in touch
with our client and we work on their
case but we don't necessarily it doesn't
cost us you know extra time or money for
our clients to be on pre-trial Services
now if they're violating that then you
know we might have to have a hearing ing
uh in front of the judge about that um
but again that's a scheduled hearing and
it's not one of these same day hearings
that are so very difficult for our
office to staff um you know those are
the areas that I think that to the
extent that there is a desire in the
community to address uh you know people
who are not complying with with bail
conditions who are committing alleged to
have committed new offenses while at on
bail um those are the solutions that are
actually going to impact change because
not only um is that person
um you know going to we're going to save
money by not just warehousing that
person um you know like you just heard
spending money for medicating them and
treating you know as as you just heard
about you know when you get to jail kind
of then they start helping you with
medical issues that that have just gone
unaddressed for a very long period of
time um but I think also you know it's
not going to address recidivism if we
you know even if we hold this client
because they violated their bail um you
know they're going to be released you
know they're not going to get life
sentences for um you know for for you
know possession of drugs and then
possessing more drugs while you're out
on bail um you know these are you're
going to get out um and these are people
who largely the reason another reason I
want to come back to um why you know
judges are not holding these folks is
not because they don't care that they're
not violating their bail it's because
these offenses are just simply not worth
jail time um and so to house them
pre-trial for things that you know if
they went to trial and they lost they
still would not get a stand committed
sentence um is is really unjust and and
not
costeffective um but um so if we if we
invest in these other types of programs
it it will hopefully and not for every
single person but result in in in kind
of breaking the cycle and not so if we
say okay you violated your bail and so
you're going to sit in jail for three
months while while either you work out a
plea agreement or we have your trial or
whatever you're still going to get out
after that 3 months and all we've done
is hold you in a jail um and you know
there some of the jails do have
programming um but you know there's a
lot of research about you know
programming in carceral settings um are
not are not very effective not nearly as
effective as uh treatment in the
community um but also in a lot of times
you know this availability of
programming particularly pre-trial um
you know there aren't many counties that
have pre-trial programming it's it's for
sentenced individuals um you know we're
just they're just they're just killing
time in jail um and they're having
minimal to no treatment um and then they
get out you know after we held them
because you know because they you know
violated their bail they're still going
to be released in relatively short order
without you know without anything and
the cycle just continues over again um
so I I do think that um again to the
extent that we want to address these
issues um creating a long list of
offenses where you can't see a bail
commissioner um to me is is not um it's
not just but you know it's also just
logistically um you know very very
challenging for the public defender for
system
correct
that's
correct and I'm sorry if I can even add
I mean sometimes people meet new
contacts in jail um and so they you know
they meet more folks who are also
struggling with substance use disorder
and you know those are more people that
they get out and use with or you know
have connections to get drugs and things
particular
yes
Y
correct absolutely and also you know in
all kinds of cases but particularly
these misdemeanors cases where the
victim does not want does not what the
either
trespass things of that
nature those are what's really
driving how would you suggest that we
would deal with that status quo
obviously not
sure yeah so sure and that's where I
come back to you know more more and more
robust pre-trial service programs um
diversion programs um we do we are lucky
to have drug court um and I think across
the state right now we employ uh number
one there there's several models of drug
court so we employ kind of a a post
sentencing highrisk High need model um
across the state but there are other
models there's even pre-trial models for
for drug court and then there are um
drug courts you can have a low-risk drug
court so essentially like a different
kind of diversion type of program maybe
you still get a conviction but um you
know I think that there's a lot of
options on the table um for treatment
courts um and then you know frankly you
know to the extent that Society wants to
do something about this you know I
haven't I've talked more about substance
use disorder but less about mental
health issues but that's a huge driver
of this as well particularly when you're
talking about these sort of trespass
types offenses um you know a lot of
times those are folks who are are just
actively mentally ill um and um you know
go back to places because of you know
their mental and I'm not talking about
victim's homes but you know they they
loiter in the same doorway of the same
business um every evening and you know
those kinds of things um you know the
New Hampshire um just really doesn't
have much to speak of in the way of
mental health treatment um and so if all
of any solution is going to cost money
and so why not put the money on the
things that are actually going to be in
effective um and to me that's these you
know Court programs but also investment
in our mental health system which right
now and I'm sure this is not news to
anybody you wait for six months just for
an initial appointment um for mental
health um and for people who are you
know actively very symptomatic in the
more you know Ser more severe mental
health issues there's just you know even
that person is says fine I you know I
want to go to the hospital please um
there's nowhere for them to go um so
that's where we need to be investing the
money I I think the challenge for the
committee is that um even if we had a
magic wand and said okay we are going to
create a 500 bed mental health facility
it would take 10 years to get built sure
so we need more Immediate Solutions um
to to help deal with it the pre-trial
sounds um a good way to start what what
do the pre-trial programs that you're
aware of that you are aware of how are
they dealing with mental health
challenged individuals like that that
are committing these these for lack of a
better term nuisance crimes that are
making the paper every day that are
causing people to complain so I I think
one thing one and and it might sound
minor but it is not but that they offer
is case management is somebody who is
actively working with that individual um
who's having contact with that
individual um and I can tell you
anecdotally but also I've seen research
you know just having one person in your
life who you know checks in on you and
reminds you about your appointments and
you know reminds you about your
medications um and cares about you um
that can make all the difference so it's
access to case management um it's also
you know you can wait and certainly
pre-trial services does not make Mental
Health appointments you know fall out of
the sky um but there are options that a
lot of clients either don't know about
or have bu barriers to accessing in
terms of emergency appointments for
medication um so it is possible even if
you have to wait for therapy um you know
long term um there are ways to get
access to medication on an on an
emergency basis that clients you know
either don't know about or you know have
trouble with the follow through um and
um again with the case management that
that can provide and and you know
frankly the the consequences that comes
with you know pre-trial Services also
you know that's part of the model is
that if you're not abiding by these
conditions there are consequences um so
that's how those types of programs can
help um as far as you're aware do most
of your um clients have cell
phones oh yes some of them have um you
know some of them don't but I I would
say most of them do some of them you
know work only on Wi-Fi um but they're
Adept at you know making that work for
them y so we've heard testimony of other
states where they have these text
message programs where the court
implements you um we're already doing
that oh the Public Public fenders off
that yes have you found that to help
getting people to court on time and not
missing getting these repeated defaults
yes I you know we just started it we
rolled it out I think at the early
summer um and um they they yes it
anecdotal I I don't have data in front
of me but anecdotally I think yes it is
helping and that's run by your office so
when you represent 85% of the criminal
defendants in the state so at least 85%
of the defendants perhaps 83 the other
two don't have phones but are getting a
text message when do you send the
message so I I believe it goes out two
days before um but I can get back to you
with that exact answer it's that's that
one message two days before yes it I'm
sorry that I should know this it might
be one two day two days before and one
the day of I I can it an automated
system yes and you can't reply to it
yeah yeah well no it might be good if
you set it up to do the morning of the
night before um maybe the hour right um
I can I and it might even be this the
two days before and and the day of but I
I can I can get back to you about that
um with regard to clients getting to
actual the court um the vast majority
don't have cars is my
understanding how do your clients find a
way to get I know a lot of we went went
to court um at the beginning of the
session to observe a a Monday morning uh
hearing at the circuit court and we saw
a lot of defaults and um I'm assuming a
lot of that people just didn't have
rides or they didn't arrange for rides
they don't some of them don't know where
their next meal's coming from so right
how how how could how do you assist if
you do your clients getting there short
of actually I know you don't pick them
up yeah we're we're we're not allowed to
do that um for liability issues but um
we so you know in certain places
obviously you know the the courts are
not far from you know like in Manchester
you know the court is easy to access but
there's plenty of places throughout the
state where it's it's not as easy um so
a lot of that is again comes back to you
know the attorney as kind of case
manager in that instance like calling
the client being like what is your plan
okay well do you have a friend do you
have a family member okay you don't
let's let's look at the bus schedule or
you know we have clients and it's very
very frequent who walk and who walk huge
dist es um but I think a lot of it is um
about providing that support um because
if they just don't have a car or a lot
of times it's that they don't have a
license um so they're not allowed to
drive um is doing that troubleshooting
with your client ahead of time um and
again that's where pre-trial Services
can step in where we can't we don't have
the capacity to do that um you know for
every client every time um pre-trial
services or um other Solutions but you
know there are a lot of defaults but you
know I got to say you know clients by
and large come to court um you know they
make it work yeah they they understand
that that's they have to they have to
figure it out I have to get a ride I
um okay questions from the
committee sure representative Katherine
here Katherine thank you Mr chair thank
you for taking my question um you
mentioned
that there's um the text message Jean do
you have any data on how well your
office is doing with that I don't right
now no but is it something that you
could get I I can't we don't track data
of when I mean we don't track data of
when clients come to court I guess I I
have the ability I think if we close the
case for a warrant I have that we can
run a report that shows cases that are
closed with warrants um so I could
potentially run reports to see if cases
are being how that stat has looked now
that compared to before we had text
messaging I think I could okay that
would be good to okay thank you what's
the average case load of of your
attorneys right now so you know by
contract case loads are supposed to be
around 70 um right now um right right
now they're um it depends on different
pockets of the state some but anyway but
85 95
105 cases active ongoing at a time yes
so 75 to 105 depending
Y and what are your prospects for
getting new attorneys by
January um we did just um we started so
we started a new class of lawyers um you
typically not all but typically brand
new lawyers um and they started in
August um so we have um you know a a a
group of lawyers that just started but
we were hoping you know as we always
hope that that in increases our numbers
um but as attrition continues it it just
barely or not even keeps us at break
even um we are um you know advertising
you know Statewide but also nationally
for lateral attorneys so those are
attorneys with prior experience um we
have we have um a Federal grant um that
actually I don't know that we could use
that for new hires but we are covering
some of our current lateral hires um the
judicial Council um you know helped us
obtain that Grant that's been wonderful
um we are um right now um we have a
committee you know we are looking at
ways to actually be even more aggressive
in our recruiting um we we have a lot of
success in in recruiting law school
graduates um but um you know with the
experience that you've heard about you
know the experience that's walked out at
the door over the last three or four
years um you know new attorneys are
wonderful but um you know we we need to
replace some of that experience and so
we are looking um at strategies to be
even more aggressive with um with hiring
lateral attorneys yeah I think the
corporate work calls that brain drain
yeah yeah um is there any programs in
place that attract students that may or
even some people with experience because
I know a lot of attorneys carry student
loan debt for a number of years to help
offset some of their debt so yes there
are there's a there has been for a very
long time a federal program where if you
work as a public defender or a
prosecutor for 10 years um you can get
loan forgiveness um but you know 10
years is a long time um and you know
there's more money in the private sector
so some people on balance would rather
go to the private sector and and give up
on the loan forgiveness um I know that
obviously there's been a lot of effort
um to to increase loan forgiveness um
and that would be
wonderful um I know that and this is
just off topic but some I don't know if
you thought about it but but uh a lot of
um attorneys leaving the Jag Corp are
looking for jobs I don't know if you
recruit with the military or not but um
there's a lot of people decided you know
I don't want to go defend people in
Afghanistan I think I'll come home and
right so just a thought question uh from
the committee representative roach thank
you Mr chairman I'm just trying to get
some
clarity because we've heard from pretty
much every single person that has
testified which we have also learned
that there there is not a mechanism in
New Hampshire to to track who is on bail
or who is not on bail so with that being
said and then if if I heard correctly
you had said that you don't have a lot
of people that are repeating because
repeating like breaking their bail
conditions so I'm a little bit confused
on on how that comes about sure so I I
mean when you look at what percentage of
folks you know that we see that um you
know pick up new charges while they're
out on bail certainly it's higher than
than I understand that the community
wants it to be but as a percentage of
the whole it's not as if you know
there's 80 you know 70 even 60% of folks
who are who are committing new offenses
while they're out on bail but I think
also my my bigger point in that regard
is that I haven't seen you know a spike
in this occurring you know that this is
unfortunately a constant that I've seen
from the beginning of my career that
that folks who struggle with mental
health disorders and substance use
disorders and struggle with homelessness
are going to have issues um with you
know picking up new offenses um and to
me I haven't seen that necessarily
change um very much that there's always
people there's always been people who
are have mental health and substance use
issues um and struggle with coming to
court or struggle with you know still
still using drugs um or still you know
committing um you know thefts to support
drug habits um but that to me is not I
haven't seen changes to that that that's
been pretty
consistent um what well you I think you
would probably agree though that the as
a percentage of the whole they're not
increasing but the number of people that
are in the system is increasing um I
mean it has to be with the opioid crisis
you have more people that are substance
addicted now than ever before with the
mental health is is spiked huge um so
that has to be driving a a larger
increase in the sheer number of people
who are in the system versus perhaps 15
years
ago I mean I I think actually if you
looked at the number of criminal cases
that are opened not just by my office
but that are handled by the courts the
number is actually decreased every year
years so what do you think is striving
the public um the public is it a
combination of the homelessness the
drugs I think it's I will say I think it
is more visible you know I think you
know if you walk downtown Manchester
it's it's visible right there's there's
homeless there's homeless people there
you know it's more visible than it was
um you know years ago and years past and
I I'm not trying to say there certainly
has been there is you know an opioid
epidemic in New Hampshire there are a
lot of ill people people are sicker than
they were when I started this job more
people are more sick than when I started
this job I I certainly do agree with
that um and um but I I I don't
necessarily think that you know these
issues are are
new thank you further questions from the
committee represent Pratt he answer most
of my question but I but uh I everything
you did good yeah I have one question
for you um isn't the attorney shortage
an ongoing thing with the defendant's
office isn't I mean doesn't people come
in they do the job and they stay not
don't stay forever they leave and go on
is that way it's always been so no I
mean yes and no um so yes there's this
is always can be you know a starting
point for people in their career um so
that yes that that is true um but this
has also always been a place where
people come and spend their career um
and you know that this is you know what
they want to do um and you know we have
I think I just looked at it not too long
ago um something like 30% of our staff
lawyers have been with us um for um for
12 years or more um so we do have people
who make a career of this and those are
some of the people that we were losing
but just kind of across the board the
reason I say um you know that it that it
is different is because um starting
actually a little bit before the coid
pandemic um but certainly during the
coid pandemic and since then um you know
just attrition has has truly spiked we
have not seen quite these levels of
attrition um that we're seeing now um
just I can tell you um for example in
fiscal year
2018 um you know seven attorneys
Departed the public defender and then in
fiscal year um 23 22 attorneys Departed
the the the public defender so thank you
so would you attribute that more to just
burnout because of the case load I think
burnout and and pay I know that many
attorneys um will go to the public
defender or the prosecutor's office
because firms are always looking for
people with trial experience and that's
where you get trial experience um so
they'll stay a few years to get that and
then they'll go but you to your what you
said earlier there is a percentage who
just want to be public defenders or just
want to be prosecutors yes what is the
the pay parody If or what between a
prosecutor and a starting attorney in
your office yep so um and we have looked
at that we um you know we were um we
were able to do so during the pandemic
we applied for for um I wasn't in my
role at that time but um we applied for
sort of emergency funds to do a cost of
living increase um and so we were able
to do that um the budget that we just
received um in for July 1 allowed us
just just to continue that to make that
permanent um and also allowed us to do a
further uh pay increase um so we have
been able to increase pay over the last
you know since
2022 um you in terms of parity um we are
still generally you know um we are now
more on par than we were before um but
there's still certainly um depending on
which county we look at County attorneys
um salary and actually um you know City
prosecutors actually a lot of times um
make more money than both public
defenders and County attorneys um which
is interesting because they're largely
Prosecuting or they're Prosecuting
misdemeanor and violation level offenses
um so our pay period parody has gotten
better um um but um particularly on on
for our starting steps um there's a
there's more work to be done do does the
prosecutor's office to that you know
have suffered from the same um levels of
attrition or inability to attract new
attorneys that you do yes so they're
short as well I yes and their case loads
are probably similar they have to be I
would assume yes okay thank you or they
they might even be higher than ours um
um because they I'm not to at all
minimize their work but you know they
don't have the individual clients that I
do so I I think that just the raw number
might actually be higher than ours okay
thank you um any further questions oh
represent way thank you Mr chairman um
so say we were able to pass this list of
uh crimes and then um the influx of
cases were to happen uh to the public
defender office what would that look
like uh individual to individual would
there be people who
lose their constitutional right to a
defender in a trial and then just go to
the trial without uh defense because
they sort of get lost in the Deluge of
of case load or would they just have to
wait until getting a trial still sort of
green to the whole system the the latter
so you know the the court has never
can't proceed um with somebody who is
eligible for an attorney uh for a courta
appointed attorney um and doesn't have
one that you know the court can't
proceed um and won't um so um you know
in terms of if we're going to have to
divert resources to covering same day
Bale hearings um you know I I don't want
to say for sure but one of the
possibilities is that um you know other
categories of cases might have to wait
for their attorney we might go backward
um to where we were um you know a year
and a half ago with you know 1100 people
on hold waiting you know for their
attorney um and I I again I don't want
to make that seem like that that's going
to be our solution and that that's an
inevitability I I don't want to make it
seem like a threat frankly but um it's
certainly one of the possibilities I
mean if covering arraignments on a daily
basis is going to take four hours of
your day um there's only so many hours
in a day and there's only so many people
we have on staff that would be though
only um it wouldn't be every day
wouldn't it just be the the first
business day after the weekend where all
those who couldn't see a baill
commissioner would have to see the judge
oh no no it's every day of the week so
if you're if you're not allowed to see a
bail commissioner and you're being held
could could you shut the door please I'm
sorry um if you're no I mean if you're
not allowed to see a bail commissioner
um you know you get arrested at at at 2
o'clock in the afternoon you're going to
be held overnight and have a hearing in
front of the judge where you have to
have an attorney um and all that whole
process that I talked about earlier so
it's not just weekends it's so yeah so
bail Commissioners when they bail
someone they don't bail them to the next
day they bail them to a maybe a
a month for exact all those would be
backward sorry thank you going back to
January 1st when we start the old way of
doing things what I Envision and correct
me if I'm wrong but say you get arrested
on a Wednesday you'll be on a felony
case you'll be held you'll then be seen
in court they'll go over their charges
for the arraignment you'll fill out your
affidavit to to see if you're eligible
for a court appointment attorney then
you'll probably end up with cash bail
you'll go to the jail if you don't make
the cash bail and then the public
defender office is going to come
involved at some point no so if with no
change to the current bail statute what
would happen is you get arrested on a
Wednesday you see a bail commissioner
and you might be released and then
scheduled for an arraignment day a month
later um and then you apply for your
attorney and you get your attorney if
you're not able to see a bail
commissioner then you are held and you
have that next day bail hearing with an
attorney so we have to get involved each
day provide an attorney correct okay
yeah that's what I was looking at thank
you
sure we've discussed and and I
understand that your office doesn't have
the bandwith or ability to do any
weekend work is there a legal in your
opinion method of being able to hold or
have a judge sit um in lie of a bail
commissioner on for example Saturday
mornings um instead of in other words if
we said okay here's a list of crimes the
bail commissioner can't do the judge has
to do them can the
Judge hear those without the full
panoply of Clerks and defense attorneys
if it's just a a dangerousness hearing
for up to another 24 to 48 hours I mean
I if you create a law that says that
they can then well laws can't supered
the Constitution so I want to make sure
that we oby the supreme law you know I I
mean do can people be arraigned without
Council yes I mean but then they would
still have a right to a hearing with
Council um and you know that would still
need to be um as soon as possible you
know what I mean the next business day
and so then we're still postponing the
inevitable I think so all right yeah
representative rhods thank you Mr
chairman
just so the the bill reform not really
sure if this would be Bill reform reform
um so was before I when you know was
elected so um can you explain the
difference between how you operated
Before the bill reform and now and what
the difference would be be now if it was
reform reform sure so before the First
Reform um there was sure yeah before
2018 we'll say it that way that's a good
one um so before 2018 I think the
biggest difference is cash or shity bail
so is shity bail right and that's what
2018 really did was get rid of um bail
what are I lost my words I forgot the
not a bail commissioner but um bail
bondsman thank you um it largely got rid
of bail bondsman there's no bail
bondsman operating um in New Hampshire
because so before um you know the bail
commissioner or later if you didn't see
a bail commissioner or the bail
commissioner held you judge would
largely could have the options of
releasing you on your personal
recognizance um or setting cash bail or
setting cash or shity bail um and so
2018 largely got rid of bail bondsmen um
which was I think very appropriate um
because um so say I saw um the bail
commissioner and my bail was set at
$5,000 cash or shity so what that would
mean is I could either post $5,000 in
cash or me or my family member could
contact a bail bond company to post a
bond so a bond was at the minimum 10% so
on 5,000 I'd have to post
$500 um to to get out and then there was
additional fees so usually for like a
$5,000 shity Bond a family would end up
paying somewhere say say s or $800 to
get that person out of jail um so that
was resulting number one in people who
just could not afford that and so then
even though judges thought that they
were giving people an opportunity
release really they were just holding
that was an effective hold on that
person um but even for the person who
could afford it that money was going to
a bail bondsman who then very frankly
would provide no service to anybody um
they would not remind clients about
courts um if you know if they didn't
show up to court I think we all have a
vision of like television the bail
bondsman comes and and takes you they
they don't do that they wait for law
enforcement to arrest you and then you
know they collect their paychecks so um
they were getting 10% for doing nothing
um and so that's why that was largely
done away with so the 2018 reform really
focused on um you know either
determining whether people were good
candidates for bail and safe to be
released and if so you know we don't
need to set these cash assurity bonds
because they're just safe to be released
or they're dangerous and we need to hold
them on preventative detention um so
that was a big change as it created um
you know preventative detention bail um
and then um there is there were is a
provision for cash bail um particularly
for failures to appear um but there's
language in the statute that talks about
you know you can't be the judge needs to
make a determination that you're not
being held solely just because you can't
afford the cash bail that is set um so
that was the 2018 you know bail reform
it it largely it was a move toward and
not fully but a move toward like the
federal model which is you either get
out on your recognizance or you're
dangerous and we're holding you um so it
it was a move toward that which is a lot
a lot of states are slowly starting to
adopt that model and seeing that um
number one that money doesn't make
people safe just because I have $700 and
can afford my bail that doesn't make me
any safer than somebody who is indent
and can't afford the
$700 um but then also just the idea that
we should be doing more analysis of
really who is safe and who is not you
know we should be looking at that more
than just picking a random amount of
cash or shy bail to set for this person
um so that's where we are now um and
then this ch would like we've talked
about prohibit large categories of
people um from seeing a bail
commissioner and then resulting in them
being definitely held and definitely
needing a hearing with a lawyer um in in
short
order
I I'm not trying to just sound
argumentative and I'm afraid that I'm
afraid that that's how this is going to
come across so I apologize it it's not
okay so I do understand the reason that
they went in I don't I understand the
reasoning for the 2018 changes what I'm
confused on is the you're saying your
office not being able to
handle what may be what could
potentially be coming so I'm just trying
to figure out how why how is it going to
be any different from what it was before
that's my question sure no and and no
and that that that's a good question I I
definitely understand that question the
difference is is that there's still that
percent like people can see a bail
commissioner and those are folks and
then they just get released and it's not
as if we never see them but we don't see
them until you know they have an A we
call them walk-in arraignment so you
know the court schedules you know a
couple of times a month they have these
arraignments and then they get Council
and then we get a court date that is
maybe six weeks down down the road where
we have time to meet with that client
and start working on their case and you
know that the first court date that
we're attending is a meaningful hearing
where maybe we can resolve that case um
so that is the main difference the main
difference is they're not going to have
this opportunity to see a bail
commissioner such that my office doesn't
even have to be involved until further
Downstream in the case but prior to 2018
were people just being held I mean so in
other words I think what the
representative is asking is if you were
operating under that system in 2018 and
it went back a little towards that now
how would that be different so I I maybe
I'm not I apologize if I'm not being
clear even under the prior scheme where
there was you know shity bail they had
access to a bail commissioner so there
was the opportunity that either they
would just be released on personal
recognizance or they would get some sort
of bail set that they could post and
afford and then they would be released
and that would not result in a next day
hearing for us so certainly under the
prior scheme where I was talking about
um um you know cash ory bail resulting
in some people being held then um you
actually they those people we
because those people still had the
access to see the bail commissioner so
it's still fewer folks right so even if
there were people who were getting cash
or shity bail that they could not afford
um then we would have to number one it
it because it also ties into felonies
first so it get a little complicated you
know because it was back in the circuit
court and so they didn't actually have
um the same access to next day hearings
that they currently have so um but by by
and large the answer is that those
people even though some of them still
got held because they had shity bail
that they could not afford other people
got personal recognizance bail um or got
um assurity bond you know that they
could afford and they could post um so
that we didn't have these next day
hearings this stat statutory scheme
that's being proposed here now would
create a large category of cases that by
by definition are going to be next day
bail hearings for us and that did not
exist before I think that any further
questions see none thank you very much
for your time so helping us out thank
you and I and representative Roy um if I
have more data about the text messages
can I Prov that to you I would love
thank you thank you so
much
is there anyone else here today that
wish to testify before the committee I
don't believe there is seeing none um
that's it for today tomorrow is the last
day we'll be hearing from anyone um last
day of public um input after that it's
just us obviously the Public's always
welcome but it'll just be us so
represent
wheeler I brought
muffins so if anyone wants a muffin it's
a raspberry muffin I made it myself
you're not just to be clear um 420
muffins correct oh thank you Mr chairman
well there have been people on this
Committee in the past yes I just wanted
to um if I may let the committee know
that uh we were able to make
arrangements for cheser County to come
tomorrow and talk with us about the the
pre-trial in all the diversion programs
that we have so uh bring your pen be
because we have a lot of programs that
weren't even mentioned um from a lot of
the other counties so hopefully we can
learn a lot from that tomorrow and be
ready to ask some questions get a lot of
questions answered and I believe they
have some good cost cost saving um from
there as well so that's what we're
looking at at the same
time just reminder that I won't be here
tomorrow if um someone else is prepared
to take
notes yeah not I I think
night